Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour à tous.
Comme indiqué, je suis Iliès Zaoui
et je conçois des intelligences
artificielles pour les robots.
Dès qu’on parle intelligence artificielle,
finalement, le sujet, la problématique,
émerge un peu naturellement.
Est-ce intelligent,
est-ce vraiment intelligent ?
Est-ce que c’est comparable
à une intelligence naturelle,
voire à une intelligence humaine ?
Est-ce que nous sommes arrivés à ce moment
qu’on appelle la singularité ?
Ce moment où l’intelligence artificielle,
son évolution
coupe la courbe de l’évolution
de l’intelligence humaine.
Cela peut être très bénéfique
puisque l’intelligence artificielle
va pouvoir nous donner de la technologie
que seuls, nous humains,
nous ne pourrions créer.
Pour commencer notre analyse,
on va reculer un petit peu dans le temps.
Ça ne va pas nous rajeunir,
mais c’est important.
C’est vers l’âge de six ou sept ans que
j’ai commencé à utiliser un ordinateur.
Et là, j’ai trouvé ça bluffant.
Comment est-ce que cela peut fonctionner ?
À partir de petits mouvements physiques,
des touches sur un clavier,
nous avions une sorte de réaction
dans une petite boîte inerte
et puis un résultat sur un écran.
Ce qui était le plus intrigant,
c’était cette petite boîte inerte.
J’ai beau l’ouvrir,
regarder à l’intérieur,
à notre échelle,
c’était totalement invisible.
Eh bien, j'en ai fait une passion.
J’en ai fait mes études, mon métier,
informaticien, algorithmicien.
L’idée initiale est simple :
qu’est-ce qu’on va faire ?
On va aller programmer cette réaction,
on va la contrôler
pour que le résultat corresponde
à ce que veut l’utilisateur.
Un adolescent va écouter de la musique,
un écrivain va manipuler
son texte librement,
un comptable va manipuler ses chiffres
et ses formules d’une façon très simple.
La première question qu’on va se poser,
c’est pourquoi est-ce que l’informatique
a aussi bien fonctionné ?
Eh bien, c’est assez simple
puisque les humains
veulent se simplifier la vie.
L’idée, c’est que ces machines
nous remplacent sur certaines tâches
ou nous aident sur certaines tâches.
Très bien.
À partir du moment où c’est fiable,
il faut que le système soit fiable.
Alors qu’est-ce que nous faisons ?
C’est plutôt simple jusque-là.
Eh bien, nous testons le programme,
nous testons cette réaction.
C’est plutôt des humains
qui vont le tester
et puis on va pouvoir l’utiliser.
Bien sûr, il peut rester quelques bugs.
Il nous est tous arrivé de voir cet écran
bleu sur notre ordinateur, mais ça va.
Jusque-là, tout va bien.
C’est alors que tout s’est accéléré.
On a eu des systèmes
de plus en plus complexes.
On a eu des algorithmes
de plus en plus performants.
Et puis, on a eu l’arrivée
de ce qu’on appelle des systèmes experts,
des systèmes qui peuvent
imiter l’expertise humaine
dans un métier bien spécifique,
juste en analysant
les données de ce métier,
avec des résultats exceptionnels.
Et puis ensuite,
on a eu l’intelligence artificielle
qui, elle, donne des résultats bluffants.
Le résultat est toujours bon.
D’ailleurs, aujourd’hui,
c’est fortement utilisé,
que ce soit
dans les prévisions météorologiques,
que ce soit dans les analyses médicales.
Même le fisc a annoncé récemment
qu’il utilisait
de l’intelligence artificielle
pour analyser de potentielles fraudes.
Donc c'est utilisé et c'est fiable.
La problématique qui se trouve
sur cette intelligence artificielle,
c'est le cheminement.
Je m'explique.
Très récemment,
une intelligence artificielle très connue,
a indiqué que sa plus grande peur
était d’être débranchée.
L’ingénieur en question a été remercié
et cette même intelligence artificielle
aujourd’hui porte plainte
et veut être considérée
comme un employé à part entière.
Là, on se pose des questions.
Je veux dire, la question suivante :
est-ce intelligent,
mais est-ce conscient ?
Même les experts
se penchent sur le système
et on regarde, le résultat est bon,
mais le cheminement, on est
dans l’incapacité de le comprendre.
Donc le problème semble insolvable.
Insolvable, vraiment ?
Peut-être qu’il y a
un autre point à creuser.
un autre angle d’attaque,
que c’est invisible à notre échelle.
Peut-être dans le visible, justement,
puisque si on regarde le visible,
cela a bien évolué aussi.
Nous sommes passés de notre clavier -
Aujourd’hui, on a des gants connectés,
on a des casques VR, des casques AR…
Neuralink d’Elon Musk nous propose même
de contrôler notre ordinateur
directement à travers une puce
dans notre cerveau.
Mais il ne faut pas oublier
l’autre côté aussi,
cette petite boîte inerte avec son écran,
elle aussi, a évolué.
Certes, on a plus de pixels,
des couleurs de plus en plus fidèles.
Mais la petite boîte, elle,
qu’est-ce qu’on lui a fait ?
Eh bien, on lui a donné des membres,
on lui a donné des roues,
on lui a donné des pivots, des hélices.
En fait, c’est ce qu’on appelle
un ordinateur.
Et lorsqu'une intelligence artificielle
prend possession de ce type de machine,
eh bien là, elle n’est plus cachée
dans son invisible.
Elle est réellement présente
dans notre environnement,
sur notre dimension.
Si je prends par exemple
un petit chien robot,
on en voit de temps en temps,
et que je lui demande d’aller
d’un point A à un point B.
Nous pourrions faire
comme en informatique,
on l’a vu tout à l’heure,
on va analyser le résultat :
est-il arrivé oui ou non ?
Souvenez-vous,
on a besoin de connaître le cheminement
pour l’intelligence artificielle.
Là, il est devant nos yeux et on
va pouvoir l’analyser naturellement.
C’est ce qu’on voit
tous les jours dans la nature.
On va tous se demander :
est-ce le bon chemin ?
Est-ce qu’il a effectué
les meilleurs mouvements ?
On va analyser des tonnes de paramètres,
même inconsciemment.
Et donc là, plus besoin d’être un expert.
Tout le monde peut aller juger
ce cheminement
de l’intelligence artificielle.
Très bien.
Eh bien, on va se demander
encore une fois pourquoi.
Pourquoi l’humain veut des robots ?
Pourquoi l’humain veut
des robots intelligents ?
La science-fiction, la philosophie
ont décortiqué ça depuis la nuit des temps
et on arrive à la même conclusion.
L'humain veut se simplifier la vie.
On veut que ces robots
nous remplacent ou nous aident
sur certaines tâches
que l’on ne souhaite plus faire.
Eh bien dans ce cas, allons jusqu’au bout,
si on veut que ces robots fassent cela,
nous devons créer
des robots à notre image.
Des robots à notre image
et nous arriverons irrémédiablement
à des robots humanoïdes bipèdes.
Pourquoi ?
C’est logique : premièrement,
là où l’humain va, le robot pourra aller.
Avec sa bipédie, avec sa physionomie,
il va pouvoir monter une échelle,
descendre une marche.
Deuxième chose,
tout ce que l’humain va pouvoir détecter,
tout ce qu’on fait en permanence
en termes de détection,
le robot pourra le faire également
puisqu’on l’a créé à notre image.
On a mis des capteurs à peu près
aux mêmes emplacements.
Et le plus important dans tout ça,
ce sont les outils,
c’est-à-dire tous les outils,
tous les objets,
tous les éléments que nous avons créés,
avec lesquels on interagit tous les jours,
le robot pourra le faire également,
étant à notre image.
Je parle de ses pouces opposables
et de sa physionomie.
Très bien.
Alors maintenant,
comment savoir si nous sommes arrivés
à cette fameuse singularité ?
Eh bien, je pense que ce ne sont pas
les experts qui vont nous l’indiquer,
mais plutôt nous tous,
dans une réflexion commune.
Puisque ces robots, mécaniquement,
nous les voyons,
nous les voyons chez Boston Dynamics
ou chez Honda,
ces robots humanoïdes bipèdes
qui courent, qui montent des escaliers,
qui font des saltos ou toutes sortes
d’acrobaties, ils sont là.
Alors, est-ce que nous y sommes ?
Est-ce que nous y sommes
à cette singularité
puisque toutes les briques
semblent être là ?
Eh bien, ce ne sont pas les experts,
comme je le disais,
qui vont pouvoir nous le dire,
mais notre réflexion générale
puisque ces robots
vont intégrer notre vie,
ils sont dans notre dimension maintenant.
Ils vont intégrer notre vie,
notre quotidien,
je parle de nos rues,
je parle de nos usines,
je parle de nos maisons, nos écoles.
Ils vont pouvoir se déplacer
dans cet environnement.
Et là, il sera naturel de le juger.
Il sera naturel puisque nous allons
interagir avec eux en permanence.
Alors, le jour où nous considérerons
que nous ne ferons plus la différence,
hormis l’aspect physique,
entre la communication,
l’interaction avec un humain
ou avec ce type de machine,
je pense que c’est uniquement
à ce moment-là
que l’on pourra parler de singularité.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)